they're coming in and they're under the
impression that we're both professional
barbers
why would you do that I like one of puke
I want to throw up everything I've done
I've been able to bowl my way through it
this is probably the first time where I
won't be able to do that at all oh my
god I eat this
[Applause]
hi I'm Aria and I do a lot of crazy
things I kind of basically crashed this
wedding I'm a firm believer in the idea
that pushing yourself out of your
comfort zone and trying new and scary
things gives you the courage to
experience life at its fullest so I'm
taking some of my friends out of their
comfort zones and the hopes of showing
them how fun and fantastic life can
really be the day we chose on one of my
favorite people a very talented buzzy
producer and Harry Styles fangirl
Lindsey Webster to join me in convincing
strangers that we're professional
barbers and have them allow us to cut
their hair so this is how it'll work
Lindsey and I will receive an hour of
training from professional stylists
before having it cut someone's hair to
accomplish this we found two strangers
off of Craigslist who were both offered
free haircuts under the agreement that
they'd have no idea how it turns out
would you cut someone's hair
no no Lindsey would be perfect I have
worked with her on a number of occasions
she was an extreme perfectionist
she just stressed out when she's doing
something she's not good at and then she
won't say this but I think she hates
talking people should test it's a real
stress Oh
[Music]
Oh to get a proper experience as stylist
today there are three criteria that
Lindsay and I will be competing to meet
firstly we need to learn three things
about our clients secondly we need to
give a haircut deemed okay by our
trainers and lastly we need to see if
our clients would return to us yeah I
couldn't really go to sleep last night
that's a lot I'm not I'm not I don't
want to [ __ ] up someone's hair great you
don't know her so nice there is so much
thank you so much
since the start
Rudi's has always been kind of a safe
space feel we wanted to cater to anybody
and everybody no matter kind of what
your background was or what you liked or
who you wanted to date or what you
wanted to look like that's kind of the
core culture of birdies I am feeling
nauseous I feel like I'm about to take a
test for a class that I haven't studied
for and I'm not in what would you say
are some of the myths and misconceptions
associated with being a stylist you
definitely need to go to school you have
to have 1600 hours here that what is
here I don't think I'll have any problem
convincing them that I'm a professional
barber but I'm very nervous about the
actual haircut it seemed like maybe
you're gonna be a nervous talker he's a
nervous I'm nervous for aria
he's very jumpy he doesn't think he is
but he is and for giving him like a
blade well it's Lauria makes him bleed
he would too is there a possibility that
they just like me as a person that
they're just not going to care what I do
to their guard
you're not wrong this is now a charm
competition well then we know who's
gonna win that I'm looking forward to
seeing Lindsey interact with her client
because I know busy hate small talk
small talk is my least favorite thing
one of my like top 5 least favorite
things in the entire world when it comes
to the actual haircut I think Lindsey is
going to do a lot better than she thinks
she will do you think it's possible for
someone who's never cut hair before to
do a good haircut in the first try I
sure really
Lindsey doesn't like putting herself out
there right she doesn't like being a
place where she's vulnerable
I think if Lindsey just gave things a
chance if she gave life a chance she'd
find out that she's capable of even more
than she realizes
I think if we give you the right point
or a really good teacher we are in the
education ta if Lindsey can confidently
cut a stranger's hair after an hour of
training she can do anything
yeah it's one extent we're gonna be
working with both Clippers and scissor
so a good starting point with your
consultation is asking your clients you
know what clip number you like on the
sides anything under a number 3 means
you're gonna show Scout I'm gonna guide
your hand a little bow okay we're gonna
make contact and just move a little bit
slower okay so start here cuz there's
still some what's there I think they got
a really good idea of how hard our job
actually is Tara [ __ ] it come the hair
come down you didn't count it first
Lindsay's gonna do great I think it's
gonna be great
I think Aria might throw up everything
I've done I've been able to bolt my way
through it this is probably the first
time where I won't be able to do that at
all you know if I go into a wedding
pretend to be someone else drink have
some fun with them
I'm not cutting anyone's skin hair it's
got him wedding then do i snippet from
there no so I'm doing better than Aria I
try yeah I think he finally figured out
that this isn't easy and that everything
won't be okay I knew this from the
beginning there's so many steps there's
so much blending there's so much
technique that goes into this this is so
much harder you got it you got this okay
breathe we could really mess up in this
part home uh-huh if I had like another
hour I think I'd be more comfortable but
I don't know this person and I don't
know what they're gonna want don't offer
want to Nick their ear but Orias even
having issues just holding the scissors
so Ari's being tapped after class I'm
not sure if Aria will give a good
haircut or a haircut at all before I met
my client I was terrified but then I met
him nice meeting I'm room all right
Roman Rome City middle my god perfect
sit-down and I sat down and he was so so
nice when you concept for me like the
bangs which I like actually I'm sorry
I'm sorry I own it I like it yeah he is
good I kind of leaned him because I was
like oh yeah I really like how it's
longer on top and Messier because I like
I know how to cut that like I can't
really mess up a messy look right when
Rome went over Lindsey he just seemed
really friendly really jovial Scott on
the other hand he just seemed it was
very hard to get a read on him how's
your day going good you oh very well
it's excited a little nervous all these
cameras around not really used to it for
the very beginning I had trouble getting
the sanics out for his neck I think I
ripped like five six different ones out
of the box and just they just kept
ripping they don't make it easy to get
those things out
what are you thinking of it all just
kind of started coming naturally to me
because of I don't know just all the
times I've gotten my hair cut and I kind
of knew what to ask him so like four or
do you think probably if for you maybe
like a two through here
I asked him what number to usually get
he sent it to I was like great we didn't
train with the - a - yeah I could never
do it - when Aria first started his
haircut he just boom went right in and
there was a bald spot and everyone was
like oh three I don't know I mean he
started that's fine Ari I kind of got
like maybe like a little warm he got a
little red and we saw his hands start to
shake and I was like uh I need to go
help when I saw her kind of even it out
I knew a template from which to build
off of the techniques they use in this
country are so different what everything
I did wrong I blamed on my training in
Thailand I worked with a hair master
down there and that's a subject
how did Lindsay do I'm gonna hire
Lindsay yeah we're gonna hire her today
she didn't wear fur because she's used
to having more to work with as far as
like how to hold a comb and make a
parting and things like that the
physicality of it came a little bit more
natural to her than Ariana
watching Arya's brain process how to
comb something hold his scissors and
then where to put his comb after he comb
something was probably a major challenge
from the start I was so scared that he
was watching my every move but I think
in reality he was and I think he was
just wanting to make conversation so I
kept up the conversation have you heard
of yes theory yeah I learned that he
lived in LA his whole life that he loves
Japan that he would move to Japan so
luckily our is very charming and I think
that's what helped the process along man
can he tell a story
tragically masters own pet died
here he actually was gored by a water
buffalo oh my god yeah it was uh it was
very shocking
Jesus honestly I think we did make a
good connection he was opening up
actually a fair bit so I actually got a
fair bit about him I learned he loves
cheap airfare you got trapped in China
for a little bit regardless at the
haircut not being so well done I think
the client was able to connect with Aria
on you know that basis of just human
connection and I think that's what
carried it through I would like to
extend a very sincere apology to all ty
stylus or besmirching your name and your
talents with my very very poor
performance today my work really was not
indicative of anyone who trained in
Thailand or anyone with any kind of
proper training he gave me a fun style I
really liked it more than like I loved
it it's it's fun oh my night fell off
there were three criteria one did we
learn three things about them did you
learn three things about your guy yes I
did did you yeah I learned like ten
things about mine let's talk about Arya
do you think he gave an okay haircut no
so we obviously defer to Viren Rachel
who said that my haircut was not okay
but I said yours was I think Lindsay
gave a pretty okay haircut I think with
a couple of new higher classes that
Rudy's she would just say you're hired
and then finally would they come back to
us come back to us Lindsay was like more
than fantastic kind of one of my better
experiences in hair care cutting would
you return to Lindsay as a returning
guest yeah cut you off yes yes I would
would you get a haircut from Arya again
I'm hesitant because quite frankly
sometimes you get you get home and you
see it and you're like oh f or something
I think this is the last time we're
gonna see that mad yeah no you're it's
gonna be one of those moments where
you're gonna see him when they were
walking down the street he's gonna turn
evil direction and when he turns you'll
see that his haircut I really mean is
necessarily Lindsay was awesome
and I regard you win 3 2 1 Arya has
very little training in this he's a
video producer you're the first person
who's Harry Lindsay has cut way through
yes
no actually cut see what she was doing
what do you think of Ari as a person
like he you know yes I think he's great
he was great personality she has to she
had the confidence but she also had a
connection really what we're in is
customer service you know we're here to
make somebody feel better about
themselves some of my clients are with
me since my very first started released
so that's eight years I've you know I've
been with people when they met their
significant other I've been with people
when they got married to that person or
when they had kids you become part of
their story of their life and it's kind
of amazing haircutting is an art form a
skill there's a reason not everyone does
it an art form that I clearly did not
master today okay that's okay honestly
if she beats me I don't really care
because this is just an experience more
for her as soon as I finish my haircut
and as soon as he looks in the mirror
and has a huge smile on his face he's
like I love this I was like I could do
anything I had so much confidence I was
like whoa like I really thought I would
do a terrible terrible job and I didn't
so I feel like maybe there's other
things out in the world that I could do
they just don't know in many ways you
won today but I guess some people could
say that I would win too by giving you
this experience where you've won and
that's true you got me out of my comfort
zone you really did so what some ways
you're saying thank you I still hated
this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so every time they cut we create that
new guy you know that actually I didn't
know that we didn't you guys gonna this
you have to a tea right here in Thailand
we do what we do it you complete
different technique